- It has a very strong meaty aroma to it.
Almost like, it almost smells like liver.
Rub that in the sauce.
(upbeat music)
Good morning everyone,
it's Mark Wiens with
migrationology.com in Rome, Italy.
We had a quick breakfast at the hotel.
Ying is already taking a nap.
(laughing)
We're all packed up and
we are checking out.
We're gonna walk over to the metro,
take the metro to Termini station.
Then we're gonna take
the bus to the airport
and today we are flying
to Stockholm, Sweden.
(peaceful music)
Thank you to the Marriott Grand Flora here
in Rome for hosting us.
This was a very short, short trip to Rome.
It barely even a taste of what Rome
and of course what Italy has to offer.
But it has definitely wet my appetite
and I am really hoping
to come back to Italy
in the future to travel to
many of the other regions
in Italy for the food.
But that was a really good short trip.
(upbeat music)
That just took about 15 minutes.
We have arrived to Roma Termini Station
and the buses, actually
they're exactly where we got
off the bus when we came from the airport.
It's kind of on the
side of Termini station.
(upbeat music)
- (speaking in foreign language)
You just kind of choose the
bus that leaves the quickest
and so we got on a bus,
put our bag downstairs.
You buy the ticket right
before you get on the bus.
It cost four Euros and our
bus leaves in about 15 minutes
to the airport.
(upbeat music)
That's the check in for the other airline.
We got checked in to our flight
but it was complete chaos.
We're flying with SAS but they have been
kind of completely unhelpful,
not really helpful at all.
She put a tag on our bag but
then said to bring it to the elevator
and then just continued talking
and didn't tell us any information.
Finally, after standing in the
wrong line a number of times,
we finally got our bag to the elevator,
and I don't know where our bag went,
and now we are trying to
get through immigration
but it's just out of control.
This is just extremely hectic.
Basically everything that
can go wrong is going wrong
and so we got to our gate
and now they've changed our gate
somewhere like kind of far away,
so we're going to our gate now.
This is such a disorganized airport
and everyone's just running around
like they don't know what they're doing,
including us (laughs).
- [Flight Attendant] Welcome aboard,
when you have found your seat.
- This is gonna be about
a three hour flight
from Rome to Stockholm.
(peaceful music)
We sat in the plane for about an hour
before we took off.
I guess the airport was
really backed up with planes,
but we are now in the air
and it is time for lunch.
This is quite the fusion, little lunchbox.
Sesame chicken with apple kimchi,
black rice, and ginger creme.
Oh and then it does say
taste of Scandinavia inspired
by the world.
Got the lid.
Open my utensils.
I'll begin with this chicken.
Oh that's pretty cold.
I'm not sure what this is.
It's like, oh I think that's the creme.
And then a lot of salad down here.
Oh and that's mixed with rice.
That's like the consistency
of whipped cream
but it kind of tastes like cream cheese.
It's like a whipped cream cheese,
is what it tastes like to me.
And then I'm not sure,
I guess that's all salad.
Salad mixed with rice, maybe cabbage.
Mmm, it is actually quite refreshing.
It does taste kind of good
but I am also really hungry.
That is oddly quite refreshing.
(upbeat music)
With the exception of being awake
for a few minutes to eat that small lunch,
I basically just dozed off
and slept the entire flight.
Welcome to Sweden.
This is my very first time to be here.
We have decided to take the bus,
which will take us very
close to where the hotel is
but there is also a train option
and lots of bus options to get
from the airport to Stockholm center.
Will you pass to Fridhelmspan?
- Yes.
- Okay, can we buy tickets on this?
- Love your videos man.
- Oh thank you. Alex,
hi, nice to meet you.
- [Ying] Nice to meet you.
Right as you exit from the terminal
there are a bunch of buses
and they all go to
different parts of the city.
We are going to an area
that's called Fridhemsplan
which is, I think it's
pretty close to the center,
but this bus will go directly there.
(funky music)
That bus ride took just about 30 minutes
and we are at a bus stop
called Fridhemsplan.
I think I was pronouncing
that wrong earlier.
Fridhemsplan.
I think that's how you say it
and our hotel, we are staying
at the Courtyard Marriott in Stockholm,
should be about a five
minute walk from here
if I can figure out how to get there.
Let me check the map.
Oh here we are.
I think we need to just
keep on going straight.
Stockholm is a really nice city.
It's so clean and also it
looks so well-functioning,
and also it's so green as well.
- I just gonna stop my car,
I wanna take a picture.
- [Mark] Yes, definitely.
- I love you!
- Definitely, nice to meet you.
- I'm gonna stop here.
- Yes, sure.
- I watch you all day.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- [Ying] Hello, nice to meet you.
- Shout out to Danny. Nice to meet you.
And we're almost to our hotel now.
Yeah, service is great. Friendly.
Everything in Sweden is so spacious.
There's so much space.
An awesome start already
to our time in Stockholm.
We checked into the hotel.
Dominica was very nice
and we got all these welcome snacks.
They gave us all these welcome snacks.
This is a bag of potato chips
and Ying and I are so hungry.
We haven't really eaten much today.
(chips crunching)
Oh yeah, those are
really good potato chips.
Nice, spacious room.
I think everything is
spacious in Stockholm so far.
Check out our view,
we're on the 11th floor.
(funky music)
And then over here into the bathroom.
Oh, I will be needing this
coffeemaker pretty soon
or immediately.
And then, bathroom.
It's so spacious (laughs).
They got us a bottle of
wine, a bag of fruit,
some macaroons, and I'm gonna
try the next bag of chips,
some Swedish sour cream and onion chips.
Oh yeah, sour cream and onion.
One of the best flavors of potato chips.
(chips crunching)
Yeah, I'm really hungry right now.
Sweden is so stylish.
(coffee brewing)
- [Ying] Is this okay?
- Thanks to Ying, she finally figured
out how to use the coffee machine.
I need that espresso.
And we are really, really hungry
as I've already mentioned,
so we're gonna go out to eat now.
(funky music)
(beep)
We are walking back to the
metro stop Fridhemsplan
and we are gonna take the
metro to a restaurant.
I thought for dinner tonight we would go
to a restaurant called Pelikan.
It's a little ways away but a
couple of you recommended it
for awesome Swedish food
and for classic home style Swedish food,
so I thought this would
be a fantastic idea
and a great first meal in Stockholm.
So that's where we're
heading now for dinner.
We're gonna take the green
line all the way to Skanstull.
So we ended up, we're at the metro now.
We bought the access card and the man
at the information desk was
really nice and friendly.
He said we could just
buy one of these cards
for both Ying and I and then we just have
to go take the metro on a group access
and then we put six rides on the card
and I think it's 20 per person per ride
if I heard correctly.
(funky music)
We just got off the metro
at Skanstull station
and now walking over to the restaurant.
The weather here is amazing.
It's very cool, I could
almost use a jacket.
Roasted reindeer and pelikan meatballs.
This is an awesomely
classic heritage restaurant
and on the menu it says
that they've been serving
Swedish cuisine since 1733.
How long at this location?
- From 1962, but this
one has been restaurant
from the beginning from 1904.
- Oh, okay.
This restaurant, Pelikan restaurant,
they've been serving food since 1733
but they've changed a number of locations.
They started off in the middle of the city
and then in the middle of the 1900s,
sometime, they moved to this location.
This location, though, has
been a restaurant since 1904
and I don't think much
has changed since then.
This is beautiful, everything
from the tiles on the floor
to the tables and the chairs.
The chair that I'm sitting on,
these arm rests are wonderful.
And then it just has a really high ceiling
and it almost has like an open hall,
kind of cafeteria feel to it.
But retro and authentic.
I'm gonna start with a cracker.
Is it butter?
Spread a good dose of this onto that.
Mmm.
Wonderful cracker.
It's like grainy and starchy.
The starter has arrived
and I saw it on the menu
and I just had to go for it.
Steak tartare, the minced
meat is on the bottom.
The raw minced meat, an egg,
and I think that's mustard on
top and then surrounded by,
I don't know what this is,
but diced up onions, capers, some herbs.
I'm going to just sort of break that yolk.
Oho, steak tartare.
Oh, yes. I love it.
Mix it up, mix up that meat
with the egg and the herbs.
Oh yes.
Oh, I'm a huge fan of
any kind of raw meat.
Okay, I think that's good.
I'm not even totally sure how to,
maybe I should just mix in
the onions and the capers.
Think I should just mix it all?
- [Ying] I guess so.
- I think so, and this white.
I'm just gonna mix it all up.
I can't wait any longer.
That's as good as I
was expecting it to be.
Oh, that beef just melts in your mouth.
Oh and then that mustard in there.
That is like, you can
taste the horseradish.
I think coming from that mustard.
Oh that's beautiful.
And then you got the little
crispy capers and onions
and the herbs as well.
Wow, that's sensational.
I'm loving every single bite of this.
I tasted one of the little
white strips on its own
and I think that is the
little strips of horseradish
because it has a wonderful taste to it.
So maybe it's not coming from the mustard.
Maybe that taste is coming
from those little white strips.
It's just an extraordinary
blend of delicious though.
So perfectly awesome.
That was an insanely
good start to this meal
and it went down so easily.
I didn't even take a breath between bites.
The horseradish was really nice.
It did kind of go up my nose a little bit.
Cleared out my nose a little bit.
Probably the most well-known
of all Swedish dishes are meatballs.
These are huge meatballs in size
and then it comes with a
gravy sauce all over it
and like covers the entire plate.
And then on the side are some pickles
and also I think those
are the lingonberries.
I think the only way to
begin is to topple off
that first meatball or maybe
I should just slice it on top
and see if it holds its pyramid formation.
Oh we gotta get a close-up
of inside, though.
Wow, that's like very
smooth on the inside.
And I'm going to go ahead
and dip that into the gravy
and get some of those berries,
maybe try to maximize some
more gravy and berries
on top of that.
The meatball has a very smooth texture.
It's very, very fine minced meat.
And then it's salty.
The gravy is very smooth.
And then I really liked
it with those berries
because it gives it a
little bit of a contrast
from the saltiness of the meatballs.
Gives it a little bit of
a sweet, fruity taste.
That is really good.
That is comforting.
And that was a big bite,
I had my first bite.
I'll go for a little bit this time.
The gravy is really good too.
The mashed potatoes are served
on the side in a little dish.
I think I'll add some
of this to the gravy.
Put it right down there
and then mix it with gravy.
Kind of like milky and very, very smooth.
I just wanna taste what that
gravy tastes like on its own.
The gravy has a very like
sticky texture to it.
It's almost like syrupy
and it has a little bit
of a sweetness to it,
almost like burnt or roasted molasses.
When I saw this on the menu
I just could not resist ordering it.
This is the roasted reindeer
and I don't think I've
ever had reindeer before.
It is, I'm not sure what it's sitting on.
Some kind of a loaf-like base
and then strips of the
reindeer with mushrooms
and it looks like shaved
apple on the very top.
Let me taste a piece.
Oh it has a very strong meaty aroma to it.
It almost smells like liver.
Rub that in the sauce.
I know I say this a lot,
but that is so tender.
It does kind of taste like liver.
It has a liver, like iron-y flavor to it.
And then it tastes
very, very lean as well,
like there's almost no fat in it.
Very, very lean, liver-y
and it just slightly
disintegrates in your mouth.
Wow that's awesome, awesome.
It's really good.
Oh, and what is this on the bottom here?
Let me try some of that.
Oh, I think that's mashed potatoes
but it has a very sour taste to that.
Maybe there's some cream in there.
Get another piece of this
reindeer with mushrooms this time.
Oh, the tenderness of that reindeer, wow.
It is amazing.
I'm gonna add on some pepper.
This is some wonderful
looking pepper, too.
Nice, that coarse grind.
And I want to taste what are these strips.
It looks like a red apple.
Oh, I'm using two knives.
Okay, let me try some of these strips.
It's very, very crisp.
It's like crisper than an apple,
but it has an apple taste.
I think it's apple,
but maybe like pickled apple.
It literally just starts to
disintegrate in your mouth.
Oh and with that pepper.
Ying and I just finished with
dinner at Pelikan restaurant.
I've had some Swedish dishes,
or I've tasted some Swedish dishes before,
outside of Sweden,
but this is my first trip to Sweden,
and I can say that this is my very first,
was my very first full Swedish meal.
That was fantastic.
Especially the meatballs were good,
but that beginning steak tartare,
and then that reindeer meat was awesome.
But it was a great,
well-rounded restaurant.
It wasn't cheap, but
really delicious food.
And I think we're off to a fantastic start
here in Stockholm.
I'm gonna end the video
for today right now.
Thank you all very much for watching.
Please remember to give it a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it
and also make sure you
subscribe for lots more food
and travel videos.
And I will see you on the next video.
Thank you again for watching.
Nice like, tree-lined street.
Very close to also the Piazza di Spagna.
I already put the cartridge
of coffee in here.
And coffee time.
Does that work?
I think that's gonna work.
(clicking)
(buzzing)
Whoa, it's like something's burning.
Uh oh.
Well, uh oh.
We've got some red lights flashing
Okay, that didn't work at all.
I hope I didn't burn this machine.
But I did put water in the back.
We just got off the metro
at Skanstull station.
at Skanskull, skanskull?